S
THE BIG MOMENTS FROM THE SUPREME
COURT ORAL ARGUMENTS TODAY.
>> CANCEL STUDENT DEBT NOW!
>> Reporter: BIG STAKES FOR MORE
THAN 40 MILLION STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS, AS THE SUPREME COURT
DECIDES WHETHER A PROGRAM
ELIMINATING UP TO $20,000 IN
DEBT PER BORROWER CAN GO INTO
EFFECT.
>> TO PROVIDE A MEASURE OF LOAN
FORGIVENESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC DOES
NOT LEAVE BORROWERS WORSE OFF IN
RELATION TO THEIR LOANS.
>> Reporter: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DEFENDING
THEIR STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM,
ARGUING IT IS NECESSARY IN THE
WAKE OF THE COVID PANDEMIC.
BUT THE CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES
REPEATEDLY ZEROED IN ON THE
PROGRAM'S $400 BILLION PLUS
PRICE TAG TO QUESTION WHETHER
THE PRESIDENT BY WAY OF HIS
EDUCATION SECRETARY HAS THE
POWER TO ENACT THIS KIND OF
RELIEF.
>> I THINK MOST CASUAL OBSERVERS
WOULD SAY IF YOU'RE GOING TO
GIVE UP THAT MUCH AMOUNT OF
MONEY, IF YOU'RE GOING TO EFFECT
THE OBLIGATIONS OF THAT MANY
AMERICANS ON A SUBJECT THAT'S OF
GREAT CONTROVERSY, THEY WOULD
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING FOR
CONGRESS TO ACT ON.
>> Reporter: THE SOLICITOR
GENERAL RESPONDED THAT FEDERAL
LAW ALLOWS FOR THE EDUCATION
SECRETARY TO WAIVE OR MODIFY
LOAN OBLIGATIONS IN THE WAKE OF
AN EMERGENCY, AND THE ONGOING
FINANCIAL EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC JUSTIFIES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STEPPING IN.
>> WITHOUT THIS CRITICAL RELIEF
FOR DEBTORS, WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A WAVE OF DEFAULT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WITH ALL OF THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES THAT HAS
FOR BORROWERS.
I THINK IT IS PRECISELY THE TYPE
OF CONTEXT WHERE THE EXECUTIVE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE EMERGENCY POWERS.
>> Reporter: THE SUPREME COURT
HAS REPEATEDLY STRUCK DOWN
PROGRAMS IMPLEMENTED BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION UNDER
COVID, INCLUDING THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM AND THE TESTING OR
VACCINE MANDATE FOR LARGE
EMPLOYERS.
THIS STUDENT DEBT PROGRAM USES
THE PANDEMIC TO JUSTIFY
FORGIVING $10,000 IN FEDERAL
LOANS FOR PEOPLE MAKING UNDER
$125,000, OR $20,000 IN LOANS
FOR THOSE WITH PELL GRANTS.
ABOUT 20 MILLION BORROWERS COULD
SEE THEIR REMAINS BALANCES
ENTIRELY WIPED OUT.
BUT JUSTICE NEIL GORSUCH ASKED
WHETHER THAT UNDERMINES BASIC
FAIRNESS.
>> WHAT I THINK THEY ARGUE THAT
IS MISSING IS COST TO OTHER
PERSONS IN TERMS OF FAIRNESS,
FOR EXAMPLE, PEOPLE WHO HAVE
PAID THEIR LOANS, PEOPLE WHO
PLAN THEIR LIVES AROUND NOT
SEEKING LOANS, AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE F